the previous episode said scar oh oh
what Jodi what have you done
not a scratch - that's weird
Lena's next door and she has the same
cards as you and we're gonna get her to
choose one and see if you can tell us
which one she chose yes oh no no no it
ain't over till I say it is realize yeah
oh no silver joke
oh poor girl I I thought she was evil I
didn't get it you'll never be over
unacceptable house ago and breath when
it's paired back welcome back to beyond
2 souls here we are
what's that I'm not sure maybe I should
you can't back out now Ellie
I mean Jodie you've been begging me for
weeks you're not gonna back up now
exactly buddy there it'll hate me and
stress is awful no it's not let's just
go
just take a deep there's no reason to
pen it's just a birthday party I'm sure
everybody will like you
I see now really my mounted meet some
new friends
hi out we go I'm gonna call him daddy
Dafoe from now on present
oh thanks a book of poetry by poet ah
it's 50 years old and very rare I'm sure
she'll like it
don't worry it's gonna be all right
I'll pick you up at 5:00 okay
thanks daddy the fall get a kiss his
name is William Dafoe
I am aware that her name is not Ellie
but I don't think anyone can deny that
they look very similar it's weird though
I just don't understand why the last of
us didn't just use uh her as an actress
instead I don't know
so are we giving away a 50-year old
poetry from Edgar Allan Poe it's hockey
I'm keeping that [ __ ] I came in away to
those dirty [ __ ] hey Jodi why would I
what did I say come on Jodi don't be shy
hey Jodi right come on we're in the
living room some girls from my school in
these dorky guys we could find was it a
present for me cool thanks uh I'm sorry
why darling I'll look after your friends
and don't do anything stupid all right
sure mom whatever you say finally she
gets the hint all right when this is
linked to madmen this is Jodi she's in
unit 4 with my own unit for the
paranormal department whoo what'd you do
there then spoon just beat what stuff
like that No Oh party time I'll get the
beer yeah do the shutters girls do the
candles and Jodi you can take care of
the music let's get the [ __ ] is there a
problem
all right now there are kids around we
have to blend in
I have to pick cool music I have to make
them like me uh what a kids listen to
you these days
Miley Cyrus right she's a country star
right okay all right
hell yeah
I'm sorry what put on something from
this century
something really popping Oh dare you
insult Miley Cyrus next I don't give a
[ __ ] what a lame-ass party the beer what
am i doing you go into my room anymore
she's totally oblivious Kerstin you're
genius uh nah it's not her character no
thanks I don't drink
I mean who drinks those Thanks easily
cast it off your whole life now this
candy
you
okay okay what are we doing let's sit
down and be awkward
oh they're dancing all right we got a
dance let's do it
hey guys can I dance too
Wow [ __ ] papa yeah see this is why we
should had to go oh yeah market Jody oh
yay
ah see these MOOCs do you see these
moves oh yeah yeah this is more awkward
than mass effect all right that's enough
I know the place I love watching me
dance I know they like when I shake my
booty ah it's time to sit down sit down
and funk it down
oh now they go back what's wrong with
them why don't they want to dance with
me why don't touch me
of course here he comes I can't wait to
check the [ __ ] out of this guy hi I'm
Matt Jodie right
I've never seen you at school before you
go to classes on base she's so awkward -
let's let's try and be sociable I'm in a
different program with my own teachers
kind of boring
I never get to see people my age so you
work with kiss and smother I don't see
why that's a difficult question we work
in live in the same lab she thought it
would be a good idea for me to come and
spend time with people my age so here I
am I used to live in London before I
moved here two years ago oh that's
really nice you know what I don't really
people but no I don't like him snooping
a lot around let's lie about a New York
man I love New York it's awesome I
wanted I wanted to blew me away
do you have any hobbies anything you do
for like fun i surf any chance I get and
I play in a band with a bunch of friends
can this guy be more suitable to
all right it's time to be reserved we're
clearly not into this guy I read a lot
boring can I can I ask you something why
are you in unit 4 can ask you something
what do you look so [ __ ] ugly I'd
rather not talk about it I'm so stupid I
hope I haven't like see you in jeez no
that's ok slow dance I eat you up for
you
Oh where'd you pick fries uh I don't
like him sorry I don't I don't really
know how that's right I don't know try
this Oh what
no no no no no no don't go with him what
are you doing Jodie no he's no good for
you what are you doing
people are gonna think you're a [ __ ]
well if I'm gonna dance I'm gonna do it
right
this game play [ __ ] color boots I'm
leaning my controller here this will
explain [ __ ] you're really pretty you
know don't fall for that ironic oh yeah
that's right I bet you do you know come
on there's something special you met me
two minutes ago
ironic again no you don't touch my ass
move those hands sir [ __ ] idiot move
away I ain't no [ __ ] I'm have thanks
pets but I'm not a [ __ ] man but I think
I'll pass
idiot this party sucks
it's [ __ ] counter music guys guys why
doesn't Jodi give us a demonstration of
her soup why don't I get oh [ __ ] off no
great idea I'd pay to see then forget it
it's just a little bull please follow me
Jodi show us what you can do okay Jodi
you up for demonstration how about you I
don't have no powers no no no III don't
have I don't have powers I told you so
guys it's all [ __ ] right okay guys
it's time to eat that delicious cake and
most important to open-mike birthday
gifts actually the cake can wait I'm
opening my gifts first love gen xxx well
that's nice babe
I bet it's nice ox knee socks a thong
just exactly what I needed
now you can stop stealing your mom's and
in period chances of finding decent
boyfriend huh my future lover wants to
thank you for making his life more
interesting
oh that's my gift hope you like it you
[ __ ] is that an old book it salsa
monkey it's a really rare collection
poems by Edgar Allan Poe hey curling
whoo whoa did you steal this from your
Grandpa's library no a lot really rare
yeah and just like you're doing oh no
you did in okay me that's a joke
[ __ ] off I can't believe we came all the
way to my birthday party just to give me
this old crap and she thinks she's so
clever she's just a little lab rat a
freaky little lab rat I yeah she's been
following me around like a puppy all
evening begging for it what is wrong
with you and she's a [ __ ] too
I never wanted to invite her my mom made
me what right oh yeah she's a [ __ ] no
stuffing a witch no we should like do
something to her oh did you with witches
you burned them ah
darkness with your mighty power please
let me out first woman I'm sorry begging
you please let me out someone say cave
please I wanna get out poor Jody is that
Harry Potter hmm my god
first Last of Us now Harry Potter my god
she's still here - here please we're
gonna use a tide we're using a 10 all
right ha all right there's a nice dress
Jody always better have the idiots
should we leave or revenge I don't know
I feel like they're idiots I want to
revenge on them [ __ ] those guys go ridin
go ahead
somehow oh it's on it's on like Donkey
Kong [ __ ] oh that's a nice cake
you got there would have been a shame if
something happened to it
ha ha done very funny Steven hey it
wasn't me
I didn't do it this time sure Stephen
sure did you do this Stephen did you do
this huh did you do that Stephen crazy
I'm getting out of here don't leave me
alone okay wait for me would it be shame
at the door is locked the door it won't
open
impossible try harder who tell you it's
Lux Keep Calm this there's no reason to
panic
the windows
Oh
off your balls and pay them Dario didn't
work what [ __ ] oh you got cried for
your mama I know I think about Oh No
uh no let us follow the voice game Oh No
happy birthday
all right that's enough fun [ __ ] those
guys
her mom daddy Dafoe they drink beer
let's go home poor Jodie daddy right
ma'am I just ain't right so I like what
it's doing with all the change of theme
and sorry setting and all that it's
pretty cool so now we're back to baby
Jodie can we sit down as Aiden hey don't
talk to me like that girl Matthews he's
the one who's gonna be taking care he
seems really nice no he's a big one he
wants to meet you go on hurry up I'll be
right here sir what what all right let's
get up
so Aidan is the spirit or whatever that
follows us it's not actually her power
it seems like no Jodie come in if she
can't control it at least my name is
Nathan no it's daddy the [ __ ] Dawkins
I thought it would be a good idea for us
to have a little chat get to know each
other a little better that is if it's
okay with you of course
so I wonder if it's the same actress
that does the baby acting I bet it is
Odie my job is to study strange effects
uh-huh and then try to explain them like
the things that happen around you right
Joanie I don't know what you can net all
right sure
hey when kids are difficult it tells me
you have an invisible friend shrug on
that one this friend has he been with
you a long time
hey I don't know actually since you were
born
is he a ghost or a spirit of someone who
passed away well they have the name can
you draw him from me oh cool
yeah do that yes do it
draw that do it doodle that do it
okay draw go make it happen
you better not draw a dick do I actually
get to draw oh come on it's like I want
to draw and be funny
dah dah he's like a balloon mind if I
take a look
so this thing is your friend and he's
connected to you with some kind of cord
is he here right now
where is he I tell him to do something
what am i doing oh [ __ ] it's a sack to
me
alright uh earthside do these there you
go that make you happy
huh you tell him what to do
and it happens yeah how does it work I
don't tell I didn't what to do no one
knows all static a line in a cage we're
tied together
he can't go away it makes him really
angry it's not my fault I want him to
leave too hmm he can be really scary
sometimes did did he do that to you no
well who did that it's the monster what
which mod said are you talking about
no don't make me go against bond stays
where are we going
well is that Jodi oh we're back after
the party okay cool right your room
[ __ ] except I sleep for the next three
years training starts tomorrow 5 a.m.
don't be late
no no no it's not after the party all
right
whoa I'm Justin Bieber what the [ __ ] I
know he was in this game hey guys
hop hop hop hop nailed it
yeah now okay
and
now I do this find you grit
you sure will mention the swing across
all right uh you have to do that I'm
really confused by this why am I doing
this
a chop that's uh come on haven't got all
day
she is she strong or what okay sure
I caught that
I did it I totally did it
oh [ __ ] so let's start again
what was wrong with that and nail it
what do you want from me
don't don't slap your sticks in front of
me and then that's how it's done
marry priest
marry prison so that's why she shaved
her hair huh
take up that make sense I guess oh cool
cool this looks fun let's go got it okay
okay this is cool we actually get to
play and stuff
okay going and on the batter snowing
I chuckled also fly whichever way the
wind is blowing now let woof
poof
I have to go there okay um hey guy
you're welcome
peek Oh wrong one yeah I know I'm good
you have a damn bright the stepper bub
sorry English
is this a training montage and K uh-huh
it's uh huh
like I read some bloggers cincin huh
excellent Jodi excellent how did he know
what he wrote anyway all right final
test site I guess you're welcome [ __ ]
barrels laughter ah finally a game that
knows how to play [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] good I know I'm gay
all right fight ah I figured once he's
punching you punch in the same layer
four different direction that's what I
did that makes more sense to me here we
go
now today sir ow damn you got beat up by
a girl that's fine
kick him in the nuts
there you go what not shooting alright
you gotta have a montage [ __ ] yeah I'm
not a [ __ ] montage I am hey calm down
pepper nail it look nail it
yep mile it Oh what is this how do we do
this
okay it's not a [ __ ] Sunday stroll oh
it is it well I'm in the wrong place
this is awkward
nice crab moves girl
come on come on Jodi you can do it let's
think of all those bullies Pooja
the hell are those what is she gonna
split Oh can can can even heal her or
something like that oh she can't oh he
can so we were supposed to
there we go
that's how you heal an ass crack how
much this you gonna do
more exercise than I ever done in the
day just by pressing my fingers
O'Shea name she's badass
oh hey sit down you sit down and smell
my knee that bad who's that actor I
recognize him he reminds me of Ben
Affleck a little bit like a younger
juicier version
this is the final test it looks like it
we're going for the flag
I double down tantaran tantaran tantaran
Adam shoot that [ __ ] we can't shoot him
wait what is this I use Adan to distract
okay it was a battle he's like what that
bow is telling moving that's go away how
about a gecko hey why can't I stupid
why did you just take his gun and kill
everyone the same
uh-oh Oh oh hey can I have their gun
Thanks I didn't need it anyway nice
position
all right let's take him to
dude that's a ladder here should we take
ten ten ten ten ten dad and aunt enterin
tenten tenten tenten tenten tenten
tenten tenten and in dead and dentin
dead and into dead and injured turn all
right let's distract him just in case
barrels hey sorry it distracted the
wrong guy
[ __ ] I'm sure we can still take him out
hey how you doing my gun eh
jump Assassin's Creed yeah
face plant and the flower Jodie
if this wasn't an exercise you'd be dead
by now this was an exercise you wouldn't
even be able open your big mouth
oh he controlled her I didn't do it she
did it well played sir just once were
smarter ma'am me welcome to the agency
with that it brother all the hard
trainings all the bottom mashing it all
comes down to this we get to wear those
glasses welcome to the agency it's like
you're a cutie gradually good move she
can finally be happy some way alright
well that's pretty cool
you know why Prez I'm sorry but I'm
gonna have to end the first second
episode here
what propose enjoyed watching they were
like if you did it helps out a lot I
really appreciate it keeping this series
going it's ask ina come birthday I'll
see you in the next one
stay awesome bros